all right well speaking of cooling down
as the weather heats up i think the best
way to cool down is with a cocktail in
hand and joining us to say cheers to
summer is the bar director from boombing
fine foods and kitchen skyler sanders
skylar thanks for being here thanks for
having me dylan this is beautiful what
is this yeah this is a chichi do you
love me
which is uh yeah a little play on some
lyrics there um it's based after a vodka
chichi drink which is like a vodka pina
colada so it's a very cool summer
refreshing drink and it's available on
our brunch menu so we're going to be
doing brunch from 10 30 to 3 o'clock
from on saturday and sunday
so yeah we now are doing two days of the
week for brunch and yeah it's an
excellent one to come out to well the
only thing better than one day is two
days of french so i'm liking this and
let's talk about the food really quickly
and then we're going to make a fun drink
over here what are some of the brunch
items or things that you recommend
people try oh yeah if you come in you
got to try the eggs per ellia which are
done by our our
head chef elia
and also there's some biscuits and gravy
that i think are just absolutely
phenomenal that you gotta check out oh
my gosh well you can't beat any of that
now we're looking at a bunch of photos
of cocktails so i say we gotta get to it
what are we making over here today so
the next drink we're gonna be making is
called the angelica houston
yeah it's a nice little play on a name
on an actress that we like and also the
uh fourth half gin that we use has
angelica rude in it oh it's meant to be
yeah so that's one of the features in
there so we're going to go with a little
bit of lemon juice here okay i have a
three quarters ounce lemon juice that's
a perfect thing to start for a summer
cocktail all right lemon juice and fresh
juiced fresh every day so that's another
great thing that's great then we have
strawberry cordial that we make in-house
okay so this is actually coated in sugar
and then we cook it in a pressure cooker
and it gets all this beautiful
strawberry syrup out of it oh yeah it's
like thick it looks good and then we go
with the gin we're gonna go with one and
a half ounces of that okay gotta have
the gin oh what
and i love you can't go with a summer
cocktail without the little umbrella oh
yeah the umbrella it sets it right off
okay now we're gonna throw a little ice
in there
this already looks refreshing perfect
for summer
give it a shake pick it up
yeah you want to get it just to the
right temperature and the proper
dilution okay that helps everything i'm
glad you're making this sometimes when i
try to do and i shake and then i can't
get the lid off and i just i don't have
the shake down so we are leaving it to
the professionals yeah yeah i've done it
a few times yeah you know what you're
doing then we go two ounces of a
strawberry tangerine soda wow yeah i
wasn't expecting that adds a nice little
refresher to it okay and then we just
give it a little dump in there
oh look at that i love anything pink too
it matches what we're wearing scott oh
yeah this goes right with your app
that's great i had that planned for me
thank you you knew before you even came
throw a couple fire sticks in there
these are ornamentational so don't try
to eat those but they are edible
okay well i think we have to do a cheers
i'm going for this purple one cheers
let's try this thank you oh this is
almost too pretty to drink i know okay
as i'm taking a sip here tell people
where they can find you and i've heard
such great things i still haven't been
out to the restaurant i'm still over
here yeah you got to stop where can
people find you guys 75 south valley
very very day drive so we're right off
of 215. if you live off of 215 you can
be in there within 20 minutes from
anywhere in vegas oh that's great easy
and um you've got to try this i i have
to take a sip of that after but this
purple one i'm just ordering it for the
color but it tastes great too so skylar
thanks for showing us everything gotta
come in check out brunch they have it
saturdays and sundays what were those
times again ten thirty three o'clock got
all day to brunch all right cheers
cheers to summer
i'll send it over to you the drink